hello there watching The Press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
time then to see what is making the
headlines with Christopher hope and
Moyet Lothian McLean are both with us
from now until just before midnight
welcome to both of you as ever though
let's take our first look at the
newspapers tomorrow's Guardian leading
with the headline Tory privatization
linked to increase in NHS death rates
oh sorry apologies that was the Metro
wasn't it uh there is the guardian for
you
the financial times High inflation
will persist in the UK
Bailey wounds uh that is the front page
of the ft
and you can't bank that here mate the
sun leads with a story on a rocket crash
landing on the moon
clearly there are more newspapers coming
in but late with the tennis by scanning
the QR code though quick reminder you
can see uh on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
so let's bring in our guests then and uh
certainly let's start with the Metro
Christopher uh what we saw at NATO today
I mean it felt seismic didn't it some
real changes in tone and ambition
to totally and if you think where the we
were in this whole defense discussion as
late as last November when the
government was talking about the idea of
cyber battles and cyber War that's where
it was all fought and suddenly posted
Ukraine Invasion by Russia we're seeing
headlines in the in the Metro this is
the big paper read by commuters across
the country Europe new Iron Curtain U.S
promises 100 000 troops on Russian
border I mean you know this is like um
again a flashback for many of us I'm
maybe even kidding in that you in that
conversation and back to the 80s here
when I remember vividly
um that the threat from Russia I mean it
is absolutely extraordinary and I think
um NATO is stepping me up it shows
um how Biden um forgive me how Putin has
miscalculated in terms of not seeing how
United uh Europe would be I was struck
by an interview tonight
um on the itb's past and program I was
talking about John Bolton the former U.S
national security advisor and he's
saying that actually Russia is winning
if you take an actual a zero-sum game
here they have gained territory
therefore Russia is winning and he's
saying that outside of where we judge
Russia in the West in Europe we might
think they are completely percent on
grata there's a economic War being waged
against Russia but elsewhere China India
other countries are less less judgmental
of Russia so arguably in some quarters
apologies Christopher I think you've
frozen well see if we can reestablish uh
what you're saying there um Moya
certainly uh President Putin has been
speaking quoted by the ifax news agency
and others and specifically on those
points the Christopher was Raising
saying that Russian troops are advancing
in Ukraine they're reaching their
objectives he says the ultimate goal is
liberating donbass and getting security
guarantees and he says the goals of the
special military operation in Ukraine as
they call it are unchanged but there can
be different tactics there's no use
setting an end date to the special
military operation and then it goes on
to talk about the impact of Finland and
Sweden joining NATO as well and clearly
taken very very seriously in fact by
President Putin but how do you see you
know this this Western Alliance if I can
put it that way shaping up as we as we
move forward
um well I mean as Christopher put it I
think I don't think that Putin
miscalculated in the sense that he knew
the West would be uniting against him
that was always part of the calculations
um in order to sort of you know make
Russia look like they're being
victimized by the West that's been one
of the classic like propaganda tactics
that Putin has pursued in making Russia
look like they're this big power that
the West wants to crash on a press and
you know they're just fighting for their
freedom I think what Putin really
miscalculated was in a perhaps the sort
of sanctions the Western plays how far
they would go and also in how quickly
the war would um be won he thought that
it would be a very quick shock and awe
that they could conquer the entirety of
Ukraine in a very small amount of time
we saw that with the assault on Kiev and
the capital and now when that has failed
what you were left with is this horrible
War of Attrition so while Russia is
making these gains in you know the
Eastern regions in the separatist
regions in particular they're coming
with a really really high price for both
ukrainians and Russian treats it's this
horrendous sort of like field of
suffering that we're seeing on the
battlefield and Putin thought it'd be
over immediately and it's not been so
what he's saying in that speech where
you know we won't put an end date on
these Special Operations is that I can
go as long as I want but from inside
Russia perhaps there are already
murmurings inside the Kremlin that
top-ranking officials are not prepared
to go as long as Putin might want and if
he finds dragging these drags out this
wall even further then he could find his
sort of all-encompassing position and
tight iron grip on the nation loosening
whether he likes it or not yes and what
was the price he says that he needs to
to be supported in this was it five
billion a month Christopher and
certainly the leaders um having a dinner
tonight preceded by a live concert
performed by the Kiev Symphony Orchestra
which has been in Exile because of the
war so it's all related back to this you
know this extraordinary event that we've
witnessed this year with the with the
horror um that we've been witnessing in
real time effectively the question is
are there splits how much money do we
want to put towards this how much do we
are we willing to suffer the aftershocks
the inflation the energy the food prices
going on
um so how long will the support continue
well that's right it's very undo our
concerns already about some EU Nations
maybe less Keen to to maintain the
pressure on Russia and particularly as
we go into the winter and energy becomes
a big debate again I'm going to start by
that the quote there from the Polish
Jeopardy foreign minister on the front
page there he said there that something
that's impossible to many is becoming a
fact today we have a permanent U.S
presence in Poland and is a clear signal
to Moscow we really are going back
aren't we this idea of a new Iron
Curtain descending over Europe yeah I
mean that is a great headline from the
Metro the Ft pictures
um president erdogan President Biden of
turkey and the U.S respectively the U.S
has been stressing that Washington had
not offered turkey anything to wing and
Chris backing for expansion uh prompted
by Russia's invasion of Ukraine namely
Finland and Sweden as we discussed but
the move appeared the paper says to help
the atmosphere between the countries uh
so we will leave later for now as I said
the the summit continuing Moya let's go
to the guardian shall we
um their headline the privatization of
NHS care accelerated by Tory reforms a
decade ago has corresponded with a
decline in quality and significantly
increased rates of death from treatable
causes tell us more about this
yeah so this is a study an analysis
actually by Oxford University that has
been published in the landsat public
health journal and it's basically
looking at a positive correlation that
is found between the sort of
privatization the selling off of
contracts within our Health Service and
an increase in mortality rate and deaths
from as you put it treatable causes now
this is something that has been talked
about I think at length by commentators
people within the Healthcare System
alike we've seen that in recent in
recent years particularly sort of like
the NHS backlog we've seen a breakup of
services but this is the first study of
its kind that links these explicitly
with evidence that this can be that this
is connected to the privatization of the
NHS and those individual contacts and
treating the NHS as if it is a
Marketplace or a business where Health
contracts are there to make money rather
than provide a service for Universal
Health Care for all yes they pick out
out the the health secretary at the time
Andrew lansley we remember it being
controversial at the time but some of
these processes were started were they
not by Tony Blair actually Christopher
and how do we know it is the
privatization or the fact of austerity
which some might argue uh left um Health
and Social care specifically uh with
with smaller levels of funding
well
I may not want to remember that but
certainly the idea of privatization
starts under under labor and I think
declined under the Coalition I think
from memory I need to check my my detail
there but certainly was a labor idea and
carried on by the toys to a lesser
extent
um yeah I mean you know they can people
can make a political point out of this
that they want
um austerity maybe a factor a BC um
other key key factors I I'm trying to
get to what the governments say in
response to this
um I'm all struck by how difficult it is
um since it allows your reforms back in
2012 for health ministers and health
secretary to have control over the NHS
one advisor was telling me tonight how
um they view the NHS it's like a
franchise you kind of It's a Brand
you're in charge of but in fact it's
being run by all these ccgs these
commissioning groups and that's part of
the problem so the government gets
blamed for Stuff Tory privatization
linked to increasing that NHS as death
rates as a guardian headline but of
course actually some of it as well other
factors in play here and I do think
though the the change is brought to you
by Landry meaning there was a lot less
control over what's going on for
ministers than they want
Mario very quickly want to come back I
think
absolutely a political point and I think
we yeah of course we have to link this
to Tony Blair in the sell-off of PPI
contracts it's been successive
governments Tory privatization has
increased but we can look at new labor
and say that they also brought this in
and that across the political Spectrum
there has been a privatization of the
NHS that has adversely affected care and
now we have a backlog of 6.5 million
patients waiting for care and these
discussions about further Outsourcing
that now we know that that is not
benefiting them and we have to look at
completely restructuring the NHS and
bringing it back into that public
ownership okay
um stay there both of you plenty more
studies discuss um yeah Christopher
wanted to come back in and no doubt
disagree but we have to move on
apologies sadakanu unhappy tennis news
from Wimbledon talking about that and
plenty more after this break
[Music]
thank you
mate you're watching the Press preview
with me now Christopher hope and Martin
Luther McLean welcome back to both of
you
um let's go to a story on the front page
of the Daily Mail which is just in uh
about Megan bullying allegations
um the story being that an investigation
into the handling of bullying
allegations made Against The Duchess of
Sussex has seen HR policies improve for
Royal staff but the changes have not
been made public which leads to that
word buried in the Daily Mail who wants
to kick off with this one put your hand
up
[Laughter]
yeah I mean Megan bullying inquiry
buried I mean we love the royal family
we we think they're marvelous the queen
particularly but there is this degree of
Need for secrecy I think which can
damage it sort of in your reporting
earlier about this issue of the money
talking about Prince Charles um some
many years ago no wrongdoing and it
won't happen again that the Prince
Charles's team say today
um but I don't know why why burying
helps you have got people here here who
fear they were bullied gave evidence to
an internal inquiry with a former
employer or even and then then they
found out this inquiry won't be won't be
published I mean people's interest is
being served here certainly not those
who are being bullied
um I think being more open about stuff
always always better for any big
institution not least they're all family
this is a great shame well a senior
Palace Source um as quoted by uh news
agencies tonight cited the
confidentiality of those who had taken
part in the independent review as the
reason why details were not released so
we'll see what comes out of that um
overnight and into tomorrow in the
meantime let's go Moya to the financial
times
um with the news that the UK is ready to
cut gas supplies to Europe this is a
really small story on the front page on
the in the right hand and column there
what we don't know is if it's the gas
supplies that the UK takes in because
it's got the ports to do so or if it's
our North Sea gas supplies but this just
shows the positioning of of Nations
looking ahead to the winter with a great
deal of of nervousness
yes of course I mean yeah the details on
this are limited at the moment but
either way what we've got in UK is an
energy crisis and we know that coming up
to the winter that energy prices are set
to Skyrocket unless there are proper
caps put on them by the government or
the cost or the the inflation is
absorbed by the companies themselves and
we're seeing here these sort of like
pre-warnings these difficult decisions
that will be made in the upcoming months
already sort of foreshadowed so that a
populace is getting used to them ahead
of time the question is how much can we
cushion the sort of Landing that we're
preparing for for people so that they
are shielded from the worst effects of
you know the upheaval in gas supplies
the the the the problem here is what are
called interconnectors between great
Great Britain uh and and uh and the
continent of Europe and often the gas
will just flow through these connectors
um backwards and forwards to where the
price is more expensive and what
National Grid is saying here is they are
going to cut off gas pipelines to the
Netherlands and Belgium under emergency
measures if Russians invasive Ukraine
puts pressure on supplies this this
autumn and winter and this goes back
really to the UK government's uh
short-sighted decision to cut
um storage uh capacity we used to have a
lot of capacity to store gas and that
because I mean that man you could level
out the price more and work and make
sure the price wasn't so uh so move
around so much well that's changed and
it and this is a slightly alarming
because if certainly this happened on
the on the Covenant against Britain we'd
be complaining about it there's a degree
of of energy nationalism here which is
quite unpleasant and I would worry about
this if the ee you do it to us there
could be problems yes indeed so um we
we're going to talk about emiraticanu
Andy Murray both out of Wimbledon you'll
see the pictures and all of the front
pages certainly the Metro with sadakanu
but we will talk about that more no
doubt next time both of you thank you
both very much indeed Christopher Moyer
thank you and both of them back with us
for the top of the 11 right through uh
now though let's look at the weather